[Music]
now bro I had a loving home
I had a loving home and that was the
only thing that stopped me from going
through with drowning myself in my
bathtub the fact that he had a loving
home the fact that I had a loving home
half this country doesn't have that so
I've had a lot of different speakers
that I've hired over the years to events
many of them they've done a good job but
there is one speaker that we hired that
I'm telling you when you left everybody
remembered you
everybody was inspired no one could make
an excuse they loved your sense of
camera they became diehard fans and that
was like 11 12 years ago and so it's
good to be with you here naked it's been
over a decade but this I live right now
there you go and so the last time we met
it was oh seven oh eight we had lunch
here I think was in Woodland Hills it
was in a some steak house that you're
like so glad yeah yeah yes nice and then
you would assess so Nick what's an
expert you said Pat I want to get
married I think at that time you were 23
or 24 you said I want to find a wife I
want to have kids I want to do this I
want to do that and at that time he had
just spoken in front of 67,000 people
and and now fast forward today you've
been married six years you have four
kids a five-year-old I think she's at
two and a half year old and in eight
week twins yes two girls that you get
yes and so it seems like your life you
know you just spoke in front of 800,000
people in Ukraine a lot of people want
to speak in front of audience of 5,000
or 10,000 800,000 alive people we have
to two million people watching on on 26
countries 20 said 20 language believe my
palms are sweaty a little bit all right
so we showed a picture so it's an honor
to be here brother are you kidding me
the honors oh it's mine Oh what has
happened just kind of give us an update
on what's been happening with make the
last decade you know I realized that
there was a season in my life where I'm
just saying yes to every opportunity
that opened and to want to reach the
world you just do what you can and do
what you have to do to the point where I
really had to start saying no
and and realizing every time you said
yes to something you're saying no to
something else so strategically
interesting and going to a point in my
life where I could not sustainably go in
a plane as often as I am and really
enjoy life I was just going going and I
love what I do I wouldn't change a thing
but I did hit burnout in 2011 and it was
a good thing
and I wanted to slow down and really
look at quality instead of quantity
because reaching eight billion people in
the world which Google says by 2026 will
happen I bought eight billion souls calm
org that's the dream you gotta begin to
know I'm not joking
but you're not gonna do it from stage to
stage so you've got to be innovative
creative leveraging technologies and
partnerships
so we've slowed me down physically but
now we're reaching like never before
just masses with positivity values and
attitudes and just it's been an
incredible journey so that is great
Congrats to all the victories and I know
back in the days you were what was the
number 320 days a year you were on the
road today it's not like that so if
there's any companies out there if
you're looking for somebody you get Nick
I mean whether it's a six-figure check
or whatever you'll be paying your
audience will leave so fired up if you
get Nick to your event that's one thing
to be keeping in mind and I vouch for
that this is purely experience from
ourselves good Nick what why don't we
get into it and I think what what I
liked about you when you walked away is
sometimes us human beings we have so
many insecurities okay we have so many
fears we have so many things that
prevent us from being authentic or
prevent us from just being ourselves
because we don't believe being ourself
is sufficient enough or good enough or
some of it is mental issues that we keep
a secret some of it is emotional some of
it is scars some of it is physical I
wish I was taller I wish I was bigger I
wish I was stronger I wish I was
prettier I wish I was skinnier I wish
there's always these things right and I
think the thing I got from you that you
helped shape my mindset back in the days
is listen the sooner you accept you and
I just looked at just I've never seen
my you accepted themselves as much as
you you seemed like you were so happy so
maybe walk me back and tell me how to
thinking were you always like that or
was there a difficult time there yet to
overcome to get to this point 100
percent look Oh before I went to school
I I knew I had no arms and legs
I noticed that but I didn't think it was
a big deal you know in a European family
24 first cousins we just played and we
interacted Nikki was Nikki right but
when I went to school and people would
look at me and stare at me and react and
then I would notice that and then they
would tell me things and I'm like wait a
second why are you judging me why are
you putting me down like just cuz I look
different I'll never forget somebody who
came up and and I thought he looked a
little funny and I'm like but why are
you picking on me like I could pick on
you and and I'm like it's not about how
we it'll different or unique we are it's
about who we are on the inside it's not
about the skin it's the uniqueness and
different person I am and and what I can
offer and when you judge someone by the
cover and you don't open the book you
you miss out on a good friendship and so
I I was dealing with bullying and
bullying has always been around you know
when you have a disease that has one
door into the room only so much of the
disease can come into the room now with
social media there are eight times more
doors to come in culturally more
acceptable media makes that even more
acceptable it's just how it's always
been
bullying is rampant and in America I've
been able to speak in front of 3 million
teenagers in the public school system on
livestream no pence put it in Indiana as
an example and we've actually done in
front of 290 schools anonymous surveys
and I asked him sensitive questions I
get them to bow their head close their
eyes put their hands in a fist if they
say yes to my questions and the
questions included have you thought of
suicide attempted suicide
attempted suicide because of a broken
home or attempted suicide because of
bullying at school
40% of attempted suicide in America is
because of bullying
40% of attempted suicide in America
teenagers yep at school
Wow and 40% because of burger and by the
way you said pence really quickly
Pence's you know vice-president pence
you were just with the president
recently I wasn't in Trump and you were
talking about anti-bullying so this this
has become a national thing that you're
influencing now so so let me ask you
when you talk about suicide are you are
you feeling like you make that
connection faster because there was a
point in your life when you were
bullying like this where you were having
some strange thoughts in your mind and
you're talking your parents and maybe
not even anybody can you talk about like
how how was that moment look loneliness
is coming to all and I really felt like
I was a burden to my parents I felt like
I'd never get a job never get married I
thought even if I got married can't even
hold my wife's hand even if I had kids I
can't even hold them when they're crying
today my son's if they cry they hold me
today I don't need to hold my wife's
hand I hold her heart
you don't need arms and legs for that
and so because I know that I was on the
brink of giving up and I actually
attempted suicide at age 10 now bro I
had a loving home I had a loving home
and that was the only thing that stopped
me from going through with drowning
myself in my bathtub the fact we had a
loving home the fact that I had a loving
home half this country doesn't have one
there are 300,000 foster kids looking
for a home there are a hundred thousand
I'm looking for adoption think of those
kids and we America we think of the
international missions we have people in
our own backyard who have never
experienced love and so what changed my
life was when I was able to think to
myself at age 19 when someone said thank
you for sharing what you shared no one's
ever told me that they loved me no one's
ever told me that I'm beautiful the way
that I am that's when I knew that I was
born to be a speaker because if I wasn't
told that I wouldn't be here so
sometimes you have to save a life before
you save the soul and for me being a kid
at age eight depressed lonely feeling
helpless anybody lose that or know when
which one at eight like did people know
you were going through this on the
outside
happy on the inside I didn't tell my
parents that I attempted suicide until
age 21 oh my gosh 11 you held his way I
held the back I never told anybody so
everything is good on the outside
everybody's happy no one knows you're
holding it inside so I had I had a
depression between ages 8 and 12 and
attempted suicide right in the middle
and then the first turning point which
was awesome I don't know about you I
have an assumption you like soccer yes I
love soccer I'm our can't wait for the
World Cup
I hurt my little foot playing soccer to
the point that I couldn't walk in bed
for three weeks looking at the ceiling
and thinking man I will never be angry
about having no arms and legs I am
thankful for my foot and my parents
always said do your best and he does the
rest and so with that faith love and
encouragement I pushed through 15 years
old I felt like I found the truth of my
value and my purpose and I realized that
beautiful things can come from your
broken pieces when you give your broken
pieces a chance and when you don't get a
miracle you can still be one for someone
else you know you know we think we have
excuses and stuff and we complain about
things and you here you come and you
completely take everything away why
don't we go back as a parent I have a
six-year-old I have a four-year-old and
have a 22 month old
congrat can wait for you to see them
when you come to doubt go away so so as
a parent when you were going through
these moments loving family family of
faith so when you're going through those
moments what was the conversation that
your mom and dad what happened with you
meaning were they actually addressing
the issue or where they're actually
taking the approach of you know you're
normal like everybody else it's okay you
don't need to worry about it what what
approach did your loving parents take
with you that was effective first of all
they said don't worry about what anyone
else says you're beautiful and we love
you always
Wow and you're special and I'm like but
I don't want to be as special well you
know don't worry there's a greater
purpose for your life we don't know what
that is yet and I'm like okay and I
would hold it back there was a time when
just before the attempted suicide
that I actually told my brother I'm
going to commit suicide I'm going and he
was only eight at the time and so I was
10 he was 8 and I said I'm gonna end my
life after University because I just
couldn't see life after University and
maybe I could go to education because I
was at school and so he said that's it
I'm gonna tell Dad and my dad comes in
who sadly not here with us anymore he he
went home to heaven last year but I'll
never forget that thank you he came in
and he was putting his fingers through
my hair insane son what's this I hear
about you wanting to give up and I
explain as a dad I I don't want to
burden you I don't want to be here if I
can't help myself and he said don't
worry I said who's gonna look after me
when you and Mom are gone
I don't want to burden her at age 10 and
he said don't worry it's gonna be okay
God has a plane and we love you don't
think of that just keep going and so
they did address it but they I hid it
from them very well so it was more like
don't worry about it keep going
you know what he said to me it's a nick
you weren't given arms and legs but you
have a brain so use your brain start a
company start a financial planning
company be a stockbroker being
accountant get employees and those
employees can be your hands and feet you
know how old I was when he told me that
all six and when I wanted something from
the store they said no make money and
buy yourself your brother makes money by
taking out the trash
figure it out so I vacuumed the floor
made $2 a week and it taught me
Thanksgiving it taught me how to save he
taught me a decision filtering process
it told me dignity
I had dignity I could do something and I
could be on the same level as my brother
and the coolest story I know I want to
share this for all the parents watching
the wisdom that my parents had was
unbelievable one day I was trying to get
something off the bookshelf I couldn't
reach it
crying I help me she's
not figure it out get it yourself
thinking man you mean Wow and I'm like
please there's no try try how old were
you at this time I was six six or seven
and I thought man that I'm looking
around and I see a footstool like an
ottoman you know what the couch where
you put your feet up I drag it with my
teeth push it with my shoulders in front
of the bookshelf I jump on the Ottoman
use my head and my shoulders along the
bookshelf column to get up right and
grab it with my teeth and a light bulb
went off I don't know what's impossible
until I figure out what is possible and
that amazing so the parenting of that
it's unbelief let me ask you have you
ever done a program on parenting like
things on parents is there a book on
parenting or something like that to
experience what your parents do not yet
I personally feel unqualified my dad did
his book about parenting okay I didn't
do a book on parenting because I don't
feel qualified yet with only a
five-year-old but my dad did a beautiful
book I'm on the front cover on a
skateboard called raising the perfectly
imperfect child and all the principles
that he did as a parent for me is
applicable for any parent of any and he
talks about in that book he shed his
whatever I'm going to read them it's
incredible he just finished it before he
got his cancer diagnosis in September
any pastor we last passed away may 2017
Wow okay let's get a picture and put
that cover up there as well that is just
I want to know like what he's thinking
to be able to because sometimes you as a
parent you're feeling that it might be
in a bad parent so the struggle is also
internally did your mom feel like what a
jerk you're being into your son and st.
this why don't you go pick it up and do
this you know they came back from the
same cloth they were immigrants very
poor immigrants in Australia in former
Yugoslavia to Australia so my dad had
three jobs he voluntarily started a
church and counseled people on his own
time and then my mum was a full-time
nurse they went into real estate they
made some money on land they had and
enabled them to buy their house that we
had with heated flooring
me in a very cold city in Melbourne
Australia so then I could walk on the
floor otherwise it's too cold so they
sacrificed so much but the amazing thing
about my father and my mother was when
they were home and they played with us
they were there mentally and emotionally
from swimming soccer playground Beach
just we always knew that when Dad was
home and he had time for us
he was there and we focused on that time
more than the time that he was not in
crime there so Nick someone look such as
okay you have norms no life what
activities have you done I've seen it
where do I start
tell me you know seriously because have
you done skydiver I have no oh my god
okay but I have to say I did it before I
had kids I would never do it again
[Laughter]
played yeah
but when you don't have children you're
like let's do it so I actually my first
time was with my wife jumping out of a
plane I think we were dating at the time
I don't think we were fiance's at the
time and it was her second jump she is
that she's an adrenaline thrill see yeah
she sees it so we did I got on the floor
and I'm gonna do this every single year
but I changed my mind after yeah so
skydiving scuba diving I've do golfing
just putting that's the the most
important part that's right so I love
all that I love soccer but I do like
recreation a lot just being outdoors and
all being at home and so I was able to
drive a car two years ago which was
really really cool there's a van nuys
based company that does those sorts of
controls I was on a normal Road with
lots of cars forty miles an hour
it was right I was driving all by myself
it was spectacular it was a dream come
true since I was 12 or 13 years old I
just didn't feel like the risk was worth
the return then I thought well I love
boating I'm gonna get then a boat and
I'm gonna drive a boat because if you
make a mistake on the water it's not
yeah but time we've got a boat then I
found out we ended up not just be two
sons and we're gonna double down we got
together like you've got a call over
there that's nuts and so we got rid of
the boat and now the dream is you know
like one of those utility vehicles like
like ATVs quads kind of thing but the
one where you actually have bucket seats
and there's two seats in or four seats
in it and you go off terrain I'm gonna
drive one of those
so we're modifying one of those now and
it's gonna be a lot of you just testing
everything you're just trying to kind of
get a flavor for it
that's it and you can't do everything
and that's not where my joy is it's not
in doing everything it's finding out as
your life seasons come and go how do you
most effectively always make sure to
never let the good and excellent things
distract you from the most important
things and the most important thing for
me is to be there at home with my family
and then number to reach the world so
how do we then bring in the passions and
the fun all excitement together but we
can all do something and I don't need
assistance from other people so that's
that's my sweets that's interesting and
it was interesting you saying earlier
while we were talking you said padam and
now you know schedule you know I'm not
doing 321 584 84 days on the road and
set at 3:20 now 84 23.0 be 17 next year
Wow so you're trying to get it lower in
Lord Way was seven he's gonna be I mean
you know some people are still gonna say
84 is a long time you know it's still
25% a year that you're gonna be gone but
so it's not like you are not you know
working your you know blood off going on
the road you're still really driving the
things that you're doing but you're
figuring out the balance now that you
got the kids to be able to spend time
there as well right that's that's coming
from 328 is good oh no believe me being
on the road and having kids but it's
it's a sacrifice that also my wife
partakes in that's the big part part
huge but we talked about that why don't
you talk about before you were getting
married okay
and you guys were
in court you know you're talking to each
other you know you said before fiancée
jumping out of a plane so obviously
you've had some intense conversations
how deep did you go into conversations
about listen if we decide to do this
here's what we're gonna be doing this is
what I want to do what do you want to do
what would those talks about first of
all my parents said do you realize that
he has no arms and legs your parents
asked her in that one of them without me
there which made me always how did you
they got me out like what she said yeah
I realized they said do you what if what
if your children happen to have no arms
and legs she says well even if all five
of our kids have no arms and legs at
least I have a great example to live by
we have said that she said fine so go I
don't know what we're the one maybe
foster she was just rocking our babies
half as if she's a baby maybe we should
do foster babies I'm like whoa you're
superwoman we knew that we were both
gonna explore a new territory I didn't
exactly know how it'd look like at the
time when I was a bachelor I had a
caregiver stay in they're not gonna be
there when we get married we don't know
a lot but they're family her family
embrace me and that's a big part that
was a big thing for me because the other
series related the only other serious
relationship I had this is seven years
prior
they did not Wow and I waited for many
years and they never came around and so
it was up to her her family or me and
she chose family and so to have her
family then Kanye's family except
straight up was amazing and you know we
were getting to know each other that was
while 320 was happening okay she won't
get back 48:40 loses 11 320s I'm on the
road yeah she was in Dallas she lived in
Dallas and I have a nonprofit life
without limbs and I was learning a lot
about the nonprofit and I didn't want to
ask people for money for the nonprofit
I'm an entrepreneur I'm gonna start six
businesses with a quarter of a million
dollars cash
I'm gonna get six people to manage em
all and we're gonna make money and we're
ganna self sustaining our own nonprofit
that's was the goal I did it while we
were dating big risk bro big risk took
it revenues were late expenses we'll
hire some revenues never came
some projects never were finished
someone took advantage of me of fifty
thousand G at 50/50 G at the time cash
flow crisis stopped for projects only
finished two and I lost all my money
this is why you're leading this is what
three months into into our relationship
interest twelve weeks I had panic
attacks for 30 days straight I couldn't
eat I couldn't sleep I wasn't myself
I was the what cuz I was so on that
treadmill bruh I was on a plane every
third day for four years straight I
wanted off the treadmill bang hit a
brick wall depressed cancelled contracts
couldn't speak very hard and then when I
finally told my my wife what happened I
said babe I lost all my money
she said straight up don't worry I'm not
going anywhere I'll get a nursing job
and support the both of us and that's
when I knew this is a she is the one
within three months nine months later
popped the question I had had her feed
me the cream puffs with the ring inside
and I said babe let me kiss your hand
again women right and I went down on her
ring finger and she thinks that I'm
getting kinky on her I'll pull back and
she sees the ring and we got married six
months later at Palos Verdes and Oh
Sarah
yeah and it's cool yeah four kids later
in six years
she's she's the most incredibly
inspiring person ever greatest hero at a
speaking engagement in Dallas at a
speaking engagement in that it was a
vision casting night for the nonprofit
and she was one of the 20 people there
my dream was to meet Sir Richard Branson
I only said it once on YouTube someone
saw that and said I'll make that happen
so I went there
I flew my brother from Australia to come
meet them when I met them there was a
group of people at our table happened to
be my wife's former boss where we became
friends she came to the vision casting
night who lived in Delos who brought my
wife along and it was love at first I
couldn't feel my legs so this is it this
is business this is like a real story a
real cool story right there so ok so now
let's go from there to the next part
mindset let's talk a little bit about
minds so someone like you you are
probably at a whole different level
mentally and emotionally where you can
have some systems may be using your mind
some happens like instantly in that
moment to have a choice to be negative
positive pessimistic optimistic how do
you process issues that come up in your
life how do you process something like a
disappointment a setback what do you
think about when you're going through
that believe it or not I I really love
the science of psychology I'm not a
person to say all you need is positivity
I don't think that's all you need
however it is extremely important to
have renewing of your mind to really
evaluate how you think because
eventually with repetition how you see
things changes so for instance because
I've been faced with so many obstacles I
don't see obstacles as barriers I see
obstacles as opportunities if I don't
know anything about marketing and I'm
going into a venture that needs mark and
Here I am embarking on an exciting
journey about how to discover an
opportunity in that education for me
when my caregivers right they have arms
and legs they they they don't think the
way that I do in in a sense well if you
look at something and there's three
reasons why it's not going to happen my
mind is already thinking of the four
five six six angles always not just
three people stop at one some stronger
people stop at two very strong people
stop at three but the people who are
used to barriers in their life go to
four five six
that is amazing did you can you so set
up more time I want you to hear
so you said normal people stop at one
time people stop at two so there's a
barrier but then you very strong three
but then when you are used to those
barriers you know you're yeah okay good
three well let's go to four five six
like without even blinking I'm already
there that is amazing that you know so
you're looking at things that maybe
another persons not going to be looking
from the moment we came here you put all
of us to work by the way just so
everybody was working when we came in
here I was moving the chair always
moving we picked you up you came from
there can you grab my phone here's my
gum here's this every so one of the
strengths is the fact
did you actually learn also to leverage
other people and ask for help in ways
that wasn't a big because you're
sometimes big ego people are like I'm
not gonna ask for up cuz I don't need
anybody's help
how did you make that adjustment cuz at
one point you said something earlier you
said I ran a non-profit life without
limbs
I started six companies with a quarter
million dollars I lost 50 G's to a guy I
closed down the rest of that money in
there to Anu you chose I lost all so
there was a part of it when you said I'm
gonna figure out a way to do this
without needing to put money into the
nonprofit was there a shift when he said
listen I gotta learn how to ask for
people for help it was there something I
had to go through with that okay amazing
on the physical sense first I normally
don't share this much but it's not like
I just woke up with this mentality okay
it is a process it's a journey and
that's what I tell people you got to
embrace your life do not shy away from
obstacles you embrace it because that's
what you learn I didn't go to the
restroom at school from 8:00 to 5:00 for
all of my elementary school years Wow
because I was too shy to do it number
two right I was too shy if I had to go I
would keep it in and I would pretend
that I'm sick and I need to go home just
to go to the toilet so it's not that I
was wired differently than anybody else
but bit by bit to learn you realize you
have to learn that asking people for
help so
sixty days after my crash someone that I
never met that never heard me speak face
to face knew about my nonprofit had no
idea I was on the ground crying like a
baby for 30 days don't know how to get
off the treadmill gave a check of 120 G
to laugh at that lives and that's when
he's like hey come on uh yeah I got this
trust me and so it's not just about what
to do but the timing of things and the
knowledge and the team of things but
it's that learning process and people
saw that in me they did not always
always how to approach me on that but
bit by bit my cousins you know be one of
them so yeah 24 I'm gonna defer their
like Nick you know when you need help do
it and the reason why I'm so operational
and I can see six steps ahead is because
there were too many times where people
in my home went to bed before I asked
one more time can I have a glass of
water there were you know there was that
uncomfortability of having to wake
someone up to go to the toilet during
the night and so I wanted to make I had
to think ahead cuz I hated putting
people out and so I have to think ahead
and arranging it because if I don't
think of it I shouldn't expect someone
else to do it got it and there is a way
to ask people firm but fair please thank
you always and you can be humble but
powerful you can't be humble but
powerful and that my friend is what you
are ok so here's another question that I
think you can give us some perspective
on you mean I'm sure you've seen with
the expense where somebody sees you and
they're kind of uncomfortable talking
about you that reaction that they get
right and so I think one of the things
that I'd be curious to ask you about is
how big of a role has a levity played in
your life where you know humor you know
your self deprecation the jokes I mean
the stuff you were saying from the stage
we're standing there saying what
okay you cannot hold them back with
anything so what did humor play a big
role in you making others around you
feel comfortable to tell me tell me a
little bit about that yeah at first did
you see the YouTube video me dressed up
as a pilot and greeting the passengers
as they get on the plane
it's from DFW bro from Dallas Texas it
was awesome it was awesome what was the
reaction of people some people believe
me and they're freaking out technology's
so thankful you can be with us it was
awesome I got the microphone when
everyone was on the board on board I got
the right thank you laser generative
where they're like what all the heads
are like I lose
look my parents said Nick you know
people don't know how to talk to you
they think you're different but they'll
see you're not different if you just
talk to them so just talk to them and
they'll talk back it so I started that
and then they're like well maybe say
something be yourself you know you're a
funny guy then I started that you know
and one day you started coming you know
a couple one-liners like you know hey
it's cold today can't feel my hands you
know especially adults I would always
find myself around adults than kids more
I don't know how that happened I may be
protecting my own self and stuff like
that you know kids come up and say what
happened I say cigarettes and the adults
would laugh you know and so that is
something that I actually went overboard
with at the beginning of my speaking
career because I was so still intensely
curious and worried about what my
audience thought of me the first
interest 3 minutes of my speech so I
can't even look back at those 2002 year
2002 speeches because I went so
overboard and Wow trying to be funny and
yes they thought it was funny and yes
but but I could see was my insecurities
and trying to make sure that we would
break the ice straight up into the humor
is always there and in fact in the in
the art and and and mastering of
communication humor has to be there to
grab that
so so you are known as somebody that's
probably one of the best speakers around
the world
I mean you you've spoken in front of I
think what was the number six hundred
and eighty million people have either
heard you on a live broadcast a live
event or heard a message from you that's
a printout with no life without limbs
over that's one a faith-based message
1.2 billion total total 1.2 billion yeah
but that means 20% of the world has seen
you speak why don't you think a little
bigger what is it
8 billion souls dot-org wants to do it
when we bought them all you bottom nah
we ain't selling it to anybody all right
there what you Bay but but it is
unbelievably humbling when when we were
in front of 18 presidents 10 governments
and they change the law to integrate
special-needs children to society for
the first time the first president that
I met was in Liberia madam meleave Salam
sorry madam so Leif she was Nobel Prize
recipient a couple years ago there are
still 15% of the world that still killed
children when they're born if they have
a disability right there in the spot the
mother ostracized from community because
the tribal believes 15% that's that's
very conservative that's very
conservative and so Liberian mindset was
being trying to change trying to be
challenged in 2008 it was a speech in
front of the Christians and the Muslims
and it's all about hey we need to
understand that every person has value
and so when you when you have those
incredible experiences it's not about
how many were each it's all about being
a good steward of this opportunity that
had nothing to do as much with my
intellect and how good I am or how smart
I am
it's about me believing that there's a
greater purpose for each individual and
I just wonderful
fill mine and they definitely I mean at
the age of 35 to have done what you've
done it's it's incredible the man
upstairs really using you in major way
so the earlier you talked about and you
know anti-bullying and you said forty
percent of teenagers have this thought
and you know it's suicide so what do you
think about is the solution for us to
address bullying like if there was a
system for you to say I think these are
the three four or five things we need to
think about what would those things be
look it's not just a systemic thing it's
actually telling the truth in a way that
people actually come up with their own
conclusion we are not looking at a
generation where they're ready to
receive your conclusion give them a
persuasive speech that persuades them to
conclude the same thing so when they
meet them being who would then being the
teachers that students got it and so
when I'm in front of a school I did this
in 290 schools the anonymous survey
everyone's head bowed their eyes are
closing hands are in the air I asked him
so no one sees their their hands yeses
they simply put their hand in a fist and
so the questions I have you thought of
suicide attempted suicide attempted
suicide because of su because of
bullying at school and attempted suicide
because of broken home forty percent of
attempted suicide in teenage lives is
because of bullying and when a speaker
does that anonymous survey at a school
in a school of a thousand people and
there are 30 people they just told me
they already attempted suicide because
of bullying at my school have i gossiped
have i spread gossip am i a part of that
and I tell him if I were you and a
speaker told me that 30 people have
already trying to commit suicide and
another 30 because of broken home do you
know who's being sexually abused at home
do you know whose attempted suicide
because of your bullying is it really
worth it because if I were you and I was
told that then I would from this day on
can I suggest the conclusion never ever
be part of bullying ever again schools
change
and you're doing a program right now in
Ukraine while you're doing a program
right now where the president's made it
mandatory for two million kids which is
5% or 10% of population to be listening
to you while you're speaking to them
you're doing courses you're talking
about this and they're bringing you in
mandatory vital speech this is Education
Department they're asking me for series
of videos for parents teachers business
it is a humbling position to be in that
is amazing
to to be able to do that okay so final
thoughts here before we wrap up Nick
what keeps you going you think about the
bigger picture what does what keeps you
going you know you've you've touched 1.2
billion people you've written books
you've heard the magical words from your
parents I love you I'm proud of you got
a wife you got kids you have kids
hugging you when you told that story
you've jumped out of a plane you've done
scuba you've done all these things so
what's now next for Nick what is a
bigger picture now with you we we really
want to go out into places we're looking
forward to going to Iran and speaking to
CEOs there and whatever unique
opportunities come Iran seven hundred
CEOs we're really looking forward to
that this August 2017 we want to impact
the world but then there are so many
people Pat that say Nick we want more we
want to know how do you change your
mindset how do you get a balanced life
how do you overcome obstacles how do you
redefine impossible in your mind and so
we've actually now started that attitude
is altitude a personal online course one
on one 25-minute modules six of them
three hours of content where it feels
like I'm Ryan you're fine it's
phenomenal and we talked about it we
unpackaged on them and I go through and
if you meet just me step by step
worksheets and workbooks like a master's
program like I have an analysis program
and then we hope to do in the future
products people want to become speakers
I want to equip people to speak people
who are wanting to do nonprofits I'm
gonna tell them what I wish someone told
me ten years ago we want to fast-track
people to their full purpose filled
destiny faster than otherwise now is
this course already available or it's
coming soon like is there a place I can
go to to see it yeah you can go to add
it to
altitude comm it's available there now
phenomenal that's amazing to be able to
spend that is he said he said three
hours six 25-minute courses to learn
from you with handouts similar to
master's program I think it's better
than master class course it's better
right but I'm gonna say it is first
class and I would never do something
unless I truly believed it's gonna
change lives you know no doubt about it
no and I listen I endorse it I'm telling
you if any any of my peers are CEOs
entrepreneurs call and they want a
speaker you you go out there the mindset
of that entire company organization is
gonna be shifted and you've made a major
impact obviously international you've
spoken at how many sixty five different
countries is the a sixty eight different
countries that's you only got a hundred
twenty them left but sixteen different
countries in and and as much as that
impacts on that end I think corporate
said I don't know how much work you done
with corporate if if if you haven't or
you'd like to request somebody I would
highly recommend then considering your
in contacting it will put the
information below about the course
you're talking about we'll put the link
of that below as well we'll put the
contact information on who do you get in
kind of talk with if they want to talk
to you about book and your for an event
and and you're not talking about a
special project we'll be working on
together will well announce that here
soon to you as well it's going to be big
it's going to be exciting that we'll be
talking about but more than anything
else brother this has been a blast to
come back and spend some time with you
and introduce you to all the value
trainers out there who watch this
content for inspiration spring a true
joy it's been exciting and an honor to
reconnect with you and for everyone out
there whoever you are their CEO or a
single mother just trying to keep things
together I just want you to know we love
you and never give up dream big and keep
on going
you